how many different ways can you
color a blank canvas different numbers
of ways
how many different ways can you arrange
musical notes into a song
infinite numbers of ways how many
different
ways can you vibrate your vocal cords to
make language
different numbers of ways how many
different ways can you
modulate a movie screen to make movies
different numbers of ways and so this is
the this is
i think this has been the most easy way
for me when i talk to people because as
soon as i start
asking them those questions they almost
get glimpses into infinity right as i'm
asking them the questions
that's very interesting man i i think
we're coming
we're talking about the same thing but
in a different from different sides
you're talking about like
that the impermanent like every moment
is different kind of side i'm talking
about like the physicality of like the
the looping of it
but they're the same yeah but they're
the same so so it's
like it's okay so when people ask you to
describe what the rig pie is or the
natural state is
you can't give it a description at all
because it's like
what the natural state is it's like you
get a second different
t you get a different psychedelic from a
different planet every nanosecond
psychedelic from a different planet
every nanosecond
oh my god okay keep going so you can
tell
after realization it's just like trippy
bro you don't you never know what you're
going to get the next moment
even though it's already like that but
before you tend to solidify experiences
into into boxes but not without a box
really every [ __ ] moment is
i have no [ __ ] cool what i'm gonna do
next it's so exciting it's just like